دوله يهزم فيها الرئيس فيعترف بخسارته
ويهنئ خصمه حدث ذلك في غامبيا الدوله
الصغيره في غرب افريقيا فقد فاجات صناديق
الاقتراع توقعات الجميع بما في ذلك
المعارضه ومرشح وقضت بهزيمه يحيى جامي
الذي يحكم البلاد منذ انقضاضه على السلطه
في انقلاب عسكري عام
94 ولعل اهميه هذا الحدث تكمن في انه ياتي
في وقت يغير فيه عدد من القاده دساتير
بلدانهم ليبقوا في الحكم اطول فتره ممكنه
بينما تعيش مناطق اخرى بينها بلدان عربيه
عهدا من القحط السياسي الشديد لا يبشر
بتداول سلمي على السلطه على الطريقه
الجنبيه فتحي اسماعيل لديه
[تصفيق]
المزيد من اقصى غرب افريقيا من غامبيا
اصغر بلد في القاره السمراء تشرق شمس
للديمقراطيه فبعد 22 عاما من الحكم 20
منها منتخبا
منقلبا على ابي الاستقلال داود جواره ها
هو الرئيس يحي جامي يتنحى بهدوء مقرا
بهزيمته في انتخابات وصفها هو نفسه
بالاكثر شفافيه في
العالم يمعن الرئيس المهزوم في الاحتفاء
بالديمقراطيه الوليده فيسارع الى تهنئه
خصمه الفائز مرشح تحالف المعارضه الحارس
السابق ثم تاجر العقارات ادما بارو في
مشهد نادر على صعيد افريقيا والعالم
الثالث باسره تلك مفاجات باغتت الغبيين
الذين خرجوا الى الشوارع احتفالا وابتهاجا
وربما فاجات العالم ايضا فذاك سلوك غير
معتاد في هذا الجزء من العالم لكن الرجل
قرر على ما يبدو ان يربط اسمه باول انتقال
سلمي للسلطه منذ استقلال البلاد عن
بريطانيا عام
1965 وقد عرف الحاج يحيى الجامي خلال فتره
حكمه الطويله بانه صاحب مفاجات
وطرائف في العام الماضي اعلن غامبيا دوله
اسلاميه لتخليصها وفق قوله من ماضيها
الاستعماري واعلن مره انه سيحكم مليار سنه
وقبل ذلك انسحب من الكومن ويلث كما زعم ان
بامكانه علاج الايدس
والعقم تعرف خفايا تشبع الرئيس العسكري
المنصرف فجاه بقيم الديمقراطيه ولا يفهم
عدم تدخل اجهزته كما تتهم سابقا في مسار
الانتخابات لكن السياق الاقليميه والدوليه
قد يرسم ايجابات عن ذلك من قبيل ان جامي
اراد خروجا مشرفا وهادئا من السلطه يجنبه
ربما ملاحقات قضائيه وهو يشاهد وفي
السنغال المجاوره محل بالرئيس التشادي
الاسبق حسين حبري وغيره من قاده الملاحقين
ومطلوبين للعداله
فمنظمة كل الاحوال وبالتوازي مع رساله
الامل لنحو مليوني نسمه هم سكان غامبيا
فان الرئيس المنصرف يبعث ايضا رساله الى
اولئك المتشبثين بالسلطه وهم في ارذل
العمر ان تنحوا والى اخرين عربا وافارقه
وادوا الديمقراطيه حين انقضوا عليها
بدبابات ان كفوا عن ذلك اما الاتحاد
الاوروبي الذي امتنع عن مراقبه الانتخابات
خشيه التزوير كما قال فيبدو الان ان غيابه
لم يغيب النزاهه
والشفافيه ربما لان الرئيس السابق اراد
قلب الطاوله على ما يحلو له تسميته
بالاستعمار وحدها عيون الاتحاد الافريقي
راقبت سير الاقتراع لتكون شاهدا حصريا على
ما قد يصبح من الان فصاعدا نجاح التمرين
الديمقراطي في غامبيا
معنا هنا في الاستوديو تميس فا كودي
الباحث في مركز الجزيره للدراسات والمتخصص
في الشؤون الافريقيه وينضم الينا من
نواكشط دكتور محمد سيد احمد فال رئيس مركز
البحوث والدراسات
الانسانيه سيد فا كودي هل هذا الانسحاب
الهادئ للرئيس فودي وقبوله او اعترافه
بالهزيمه على طريقه الديمقراطيات الغربيه
وفق ادبيات وقبوله ايضا بالنزول من الشجره
بعد 22 سنه من الحكم المتسلط هل لايمانه
العميق بقيم الديمقراطيه وهو القائل بانه
سيحكم لمليار
سنه من الصعب ان نحكم لان هذا الامر كان
غير متوقع بالنسبه اليه فصدمه حقا هي ليست
في خساره الانتخابات ولكن بالنسبه اليه
الخساره هي التخلي عن السلطه بهذه السهوله
وفي الحقيقه كان الامر مط كان عندما قام
بدعوه
الصحفيين الى لقاء الحكومي ووجه دعوه الى
اداما بارو بانه قبل الهزيمه هذا كان
مذهلا ومفاجئا ان كان هذا اشاره لما هو
قادم علينا ان ننتظر لنرى ولكنني اعتقد
بان هناك امرا مربكا هنا فانا لا
اثق بان هذا سوف يكون عمليه انتقاليه
سلميه بالنظر الى
البيانات والاقوال التي ادلى بها يحيى
جامي في الماضي فقد تحدث كثيرا عن حقه بان
يقود شعب جامبيا وقال كما قلتم محقين بانه
سوف يقود البلد الى حتى مليار عام اذا
فالامر ليس من الممكن ان نجزم بشانه الان
الرئيس المهزوم جاهزا للهر نحو باب الخروج
والقبول بالانسحاب هل لانه ادرك فعلا عدم
قدرته على الصمود في هذه الانتخابات
والنجاح ام حتى لا يفوته الاوان وينكل به
كما نكل هو بخصومه
ومعارضيه شكرا لكم اخي الكريم على هذه
السانحه اعتقد ان السياق الذي يمكن ان
تتنزل فيه الانتخاب الجانبيه يختلف
باختلاف الدول الافريقيه عموما فهناك دول
ذهبت من التمديد الى التابيد وبعضها ذهب
في انتخابات شفافه ونزيهه في غرب افريقيا
وبعضها ما زال ايضا يرزح تحت ازمات وهزات
عنيفه بسبب الانتخابات والانتكاسات
والانقلابات اعتقد ان غامبيا رغم انها
جزيره فرط عليها الجغرافيا اكراهات العزله
فان السياسه ايضا وامتداداتها فرط عليها
اكراهات العزله كذلك الثقافه فهي دوله
انجل سكسونيه في فضاء غرب افريقيا
الفرانكفوني اعتقد ان هناك سياقين اثنين
يجعلنا نستطيع ان نفهم الدرس الجامبي
السياق الاول سياق موضوعي يتعلق بوحده
المعارضه مما يغري و ايضا يجعله درسا
للمعارضات في الدول الافريقيه بان تتوحد
جهودها في نسق سياسي واحد وخلال مرشح واحد
الملاحظه الثانيه تتعلق ب راهات الغربي
رغم عدم رعايته مؤخرا لما يسمى
بالديمقراطيه في افريقيا فلم يعد ايضا من
اكثر المدافعين عنها ولحامين لها خاصه ان
افق التوقع مع نجاح ترامب ل لن يكون كثيرا
الملاحظه المتعلقه الاخرى بسياق الجامبي
تتعلق
بان الرئيس الجامبي انسحب اخيرا من من
محكمه الجنايات الدوليه وهو يتوقع ويرى
محاكمات رؤساء افارقه في مناطق مختلفه
ويخشى على نفسه من انقلابات هزت جامبيا
سابقا وقد يكون هذا الدرس الجامبي درسا له
ودرسا ايضا و جنب جامبيا درس الهزيمه امام
صناديق الاقتراع بين الشعب والحكومه او
بين الشعب والجيش السيد السييد فا كودي
بناء على المثال الجمبي مهما كانت حسن
النوايا او او سوءها هل يمكن ان نتحدث عن
نضج ما في التجربه الديمقراطيه في افريقيا
عن اقتراب ما لعقل الممارسه الديمقراطيه
وتصليب عودها وفي البال النموذج
السنغالي الهام جدا في في القاره هل نحن
امام
ديمقراطيه قادمه على مهل في
افريقيا نعم بكل
تاكيد لكي لا نبتعد عن الامر حتى نيجيريا
راينا عمليه انتقاليه سلميه في السابق
عندما الرئيس جودلاك
جونثان سلم السلطه الى محمد البخاري اذا
فهناك هذا النوع من النضج في افريقيا حيث
اننا نرى مزيدا من العمليات الانتخابيه
ولكن السؤال هل الانتخابات حقا تفضي الى
ديمقراطيه فالناس
مازالوا يواجهون صعوبات سياسيه وخاصه فيما
يتعلق بالحقوق الاساسيه حيث يجب الناس ان
يتمتعوا بها ايضا الحقوق الاقتصاديه
والتحديات التي تواجهها الدول الافريقيه
وخاصه تلك التي عقدت عمليات الانتخابيه ما
زالت تسير فيها اذا نعم هناك انتخابات
ولكنني لا اعتقد ان علينا ان نحتفل بسرعه
بالقول بان الانتخابات قد تترجم الى
ديمقراطيه دكتور فال في مقابل ما تشهده
افريقيا عموما من اندفاع نحو البناء
الديمقراطي كيف يفسر انحسار التجربه
الديمقراطيه في الدول العربيه مع انها لها
مشروع مشروع يعني نهضه ومشروع كبير منذ
قرن كامل ورغم الرياح رياح الربيع الهربي
التي هبت وحملت امال
كثيره هذا يشرع السؤال اجاب عليه بعض
المهتمين بالشان العربي والافريقي او ما
مهتمين بالاستثناء العربي او الاستثناء
الافريقي لا يمكن ان نقول ان ان الربيع
العربي فشل شمالا وتجه جنوبا ف
الديمقراطيه في افريقيا او ما نجح من
الديمقرا افريقيا هو ما يسمى بديمقراطية
سلس وان كان مع مخاض عسير
بعضون
وكباقي وقع مع بعض الدول الا اسف لان
الوقت انتهى يعني لدينا النشره على راس
الساعه اشكرك دكتور محمد سيد احمد فال
رئيس مركز البحوث والدراسات الانسانيه
منشط واشكر السيد تبيس فكو الباحث في مركز
الجزيره للدراسات والمتخصص في الشؤون
الافريقيه شكرا لكم مشاهدينا الكرام بهذا
نصل النهايه الحصاد الى اللقاء